i am very happy to have tonight's guest
in studio with me he's a very talented
comedian the author
of the new york times bestseller how to
be black
he stole my title and the host of the
podcast
how to citizen with uh baratunde
where he speaks with people working to
improve society
for the many please welcome baratunde
thurston
thanks so much for being here thank you
for being here
i have no choice you had a choice i did
you
chose to be here i must be here i'm
contractually obliged but i'm really
happy
uh when we can get someone to come uh
into the studio it makes my day
and so thanks for doing this thanks for
getting me out of the house you were
married
very recently during covid yes
yes we took 2020 and we said we're going
to change the headline on the whole year
and so 2020 is no longer just the year
of covet and loss and death and
racial uprising it's the year we got
married oh that's nice
so is that what you're going to say is
you're going to say it was the year we
got married first are you going to
mention all the other stuff
but we always have to mention it's a
contractual obligation
according to the thing we signed with
the county did you put that all on the
case
because that would be kind of a downer
um well congratulations uh i'm very
happy for you
and and here's what i want to talk about
uh your podcast there
as we know there's a lot of podcasts out
there i think yours is very important
and i'm so glad that you're doing it
uh how to citizen uh and
and it's all about having a positive
impact
and one of the things that intrigues me
about this or draws me to it naturally
is that
i uh i like to think a lot of people we
get worn down by the negativity out
there right now
really worn down and so what i like
is that you are approaching this as it
doesn't have to be this way
and life could be a lot better and
there are very simple things we can do
yeah to make our lives better
so first of all how did this idea come
about
why did is this have you always been the
person that wanted to make this kind of
positive change
kind of i've been a news junkie my whole
life i've been about making the world
better my mother was a very political
person
and wanted to make sure that i was
involved in the world so we went to
marches together and we worked at soup
kitchens together and we did
all kinds of things together so i i
think a lot of my life has led to making
something like this
yeah but recently that negativity you
talked about was getting to me
yeah and i'm a pretty positive person
like my default setting is
belief in people um and the world was
really challenging
that orientation and continues to yes um
but what i held on to was we can make it
better and taking this word citizen
make it a verb instead of this
leadership it's really interesting yes
yeah you took it most people use it as a
noun this is a citizen that's a citizen
and you said no we need to
citizen yeah and i thought i like that
expound please
well we live in this thing allegedly
called democracy
which means people power yeah so at the
end of the day
it's us this whole system of government
this whole way we interact with our
neighbors and what we get out of society
we can change that we can remix it and
make it what we want and i often forget
as open-minded and invested as i've been
in trying to make change
you can get to feel depressed
angry and overwhelmed
by the size of all these challenges so i
also knew there was another story that
the news wasn't telling us about the
people working to make things better
and how do we find those people what can
they help us figure out how to do
so we are in our second season now and
we're taking on this whole thing about
division
but we're doing it through money through
the economy right
because the economy is one of the things
that divides us most from each other
folks who are doing really well
folks who are doing really badly and it
doesn't have to be that way so we found
some people building an economy that
does
a bit better for us and my goal our goal
is you leave these episodes
and you're like i maybe didn't know that
and i have something i can do
because the news also has left me
feeling so
empty yeah where i was like i know i can
scream i definitely want to punch
something right now
right but that's not helping in the it's
not helping my community
sometimes it helps in the very short
term
there are a few occasions every now and
then where punching somebody or
something does help
very rare very rare i'm not recommending
it i don't want to make a categorical
decision
no no and i'm with you on that but the
occasionally the screaming and the
punching
yeah quite useful yeah uh especially
growing up in my family
uh got me out of some jams you know
speaking of growing up i want to talk
first of all about your background
and then go back to this but you grew up
in dc yeah the nation i know that
and um you said you were a news junkie
as a kid which uh
some people describe themselves as an
adult as a news junkie i don't often
hear people
say i was a news junkie when i was a kid
yeah describe how much of a news junkie
were you i was a very popular kid first
of all
yeah i imagine super super cool and
that guy's a really amazing football
player but that guy knows the news he
knows what's going on
like he's trying to inform the citizenry
what a democracy nerd
so mom comes back to my mom we were in
the car a lot
and we had npr on a lot and the local uh
station wpfw
black owned radio station out of dc we
watched pbs that wasn't my cable network
it was public broadcasting right
so other kids were like we gotta we're
gonna stay up late and watch some cable
it meant something erratic information
and uh and i guess i got so far so we
got the sunday newspaper and i would
read it like cover the cover it's great
the washington post um my mom had a
subscription to this very nerdy
tech magazine called information week so
i read that too because it was like
around
and when i got bored in class i would in
my earphones
listen to the news instead of the
teacher wow that's how much of a news
junkie i was
right i was the copy aide kind of an
intern role at the washington post
during my summers and even
in the evenings during the school year
did you ever like find yourself saying i
gotta go i've gotta see the evening news
i've gotta leave right now
when i would come home from school i
would race to get home so i could watch
tom brokaw in the nbc nightly dude
no one's ever said that i'm an original
baby
i'm an original and i love tom brokaw no
no dis to tom brokaw but no one under 70
has ever said
where are we've got to get home tom
brokaw's on with the nightly news and
there was no dvr-ing back in the 80s
then no
you really had to catch it live you had
to be there you had to be committed
so uh you grew up in d.c and tell me
uh i'm curious because i know that one
of the
causes that you're interested in is
statehood
for d.c something that means means a lot
to you
let's talk about that yeah let's talk
about basic extension of human and
constitutional rights to the residents
of the union which
i'm against okay you knew that when you
came right yeah but i thought maybe
i wanted this to be a healthy debate
um so yeah so let's talk about that
because
uh one of the things that has been
suggested many times is that
uh dc uh could be a state puerto rico
statehood for puerto rico and this is a
threatening concept
yeah to uh people in this country talk
about that to republican people to white
republican people who don't like the
idea
of black people voting which is why that
party has made it kind of an official
policy to make it very hard for black
people to vote
listen um we in this nation
were so serious about being represented
by our government
that we took the previous government's
tea and dumped it into the harbor
like all the tea and we were close to
britain at that time so i think
americans
as they existed loved tea yeah it was a
big sacrifice
to take all that and send king george
back and we had a whole war over
taxation
without representation and then in the
seat of power in our own government in
our own nation
we don't extend that to the people of dc
and i take it personally because i grew
up there because my mother grew up there
my father grew up there my grandparents
in many cases grew up there and dc is
full of people still mostly black people
a lot of them work for the federal
government making all this stuff
possible
and you want to take all those benefits
and all those goodies but not let those
people have a real senator we have a
shadow senator
yeah that's like a bad joke right so
let's just
let's on with a democracy let's move
this should be an easy there should be a
gimme we can't be proclaiming democracy
all over the world
and denying representation to the people
in our own capital
plus the people to puerto rico it's
clear to me that that
and i think to a lot of people that
there's um
fear is driving a lot of decisions uh in
if by people in this country uh and when
i say people i mean
there are people that feel and i think
this has often been the case
historically my way of life is being
threatened
and um we need to hang on to our way of
life and these are all sort of coded
phrases for we need to hang on to our
power
yeah and the demographics in this
country are changing things are changing
and oh wait a minute parts of the south
are
are voting for uh democrats uh and
this is scary and we're starting to lose
our grip
and so it's fear i think is is is is
that how you see it
i think fear is a great word because a
lot of folks in this country have been
convinced
that the system was great for them
right and that's a story it's a it's a
convincing and compelling story powered
by a bunch of propaganda
like confederate statues as one small
example and a bunch of lies
and the tragedy is that this lie has
lived for so long
that we should hoard all these resources
for a few people that we could tell this
story that
those aren't even people that's what we
convinced ourselves of collectively
they're not even human therefore do what
you want deny them rights kill them
whenever you want to
and so the other side of that has also
suffered
right if you're living under this lie
that you're better than everybody else
then you think everything you got you
just
deserved and worked hard that's a
that's a painful miscalculation and
misunderstanding of how the world works
and i think it limits what we can be
because if folks let go of that fear
we can have a lot more stuff we talking
about this in the podcast and how the
citizen
because i think about it this way people
talk about how great america has been
right we want to go back to the we went
to the moon we defeated the nazis
imagine how much more we could have done
if we let everybody
in right let everybody participate we
could have been to mars
if we let women have bank accounts you
know what i mean like we could have
done so many more greater things with
the greatness that lies in all of our
people
so i understand the fear because i'm a
human being and i know there are things
that i'm holding on to
that i'm afraid to let go of but i also
know from personal experience that when
you face that fear
you let it go it's a great release and a
great relief and it opens us up to the
possibility of something
bigger and better so that's what i hope
for us that's part of what i do what i
do it through all the dark days and
we're living through some
darknesses all the time the pandemic is
not a fun time
right what's happening in minneapolis
and across the nation is not fun
but i see the potential to have a
different narrative that isn't based in
that fear you just talked about
you know it's interesting because you're
talking this year on the podcast about
the economy and the economic divide
and this is something i think about all
the time and yes
uh you know racial issues and racial
divisions have been with us
since the beginning since the beginning
of this country's uh you know
history has written into our code yeah
it is it is literally written into the
the dna
of our of our constitution sadly uh
and but what has happened
more recently is the division
between the haves and the half knots is
getting more and more extreme
it's getting to levels that probably
exceed what we saw in the 1890s you know
the gilded age when
people thought well that'll never happen
again when you have you have occasional
rockefellers and then everyone else
has nothing and has to work their entire
life
and and never get out of a slum it feels
like the
people feel the middle class is slipping
away and
this is a big part of what you're
talking about this year on the podcast
absolutely i mean
january 6 was a dramatic moment
in terms of the attack on the capital on
our democracy and if you didn't think we
were divided before then you saw that
you're like oh
i think we're a bit divided and so what
do we do about that do we
talk about bipartisanship vaguely as
some north star
or do we try to dig deeper into what is
at the root of this
and i think it's not an either or thing
the racial
the kind of codification of racial
discrimination
and the excess and the separation of
money and how we've done capitalism here
they're intertwined
we denied labor rights to
certain people as we expanded them for
others the whole union movement was very
segregated
in the beginning and now we see a
concentration of power handful of a few
companies
grabbing all the goodies handful of
people owning more than half the people
that's ridiculous
and we have this really perverse
situation where
folks are working really hard one job
two job three job four
and still can't afford their homes
we've heard the argument so many of us
uh the system is rigged
it's winners versus losers winners take
oh i get all that
so what's the other way to do it and
it's it's more democracy dude
like it's more of us showing up it's
being citizens in an active sense not
just in this legal
i was born here since right when people
are afraid you know to me there's a lot
of obstructionism
when people get afraid they cross their
arms and they say
nope nope nope and literally that's
what's happening in the filibuster
that's happening that's what a lot of i
think mitch mcconnell's about is no
no no no no he's not the part that i um
i so sometimes want to like vilify all
republicans
right and then i have to check myself
yeah
and i look at the numbers and you look
at you know this voting
anti-voting situation in georgia
the majority of the people of georgia
didn't want that either right
there's a in some cases it's literally a
handful of people
who are overriding the will of the
people yeah
as pseudo-duly elected representatives
who chose their voters more than their
voters got to choose them
because of gerrymandering and all these
other shenanigans and
they're forcing things down the people's
throat
so we all have to wake up i do look
forward to a real debate with an actual
republican if we could find one
i don't think mitch mcconnell is
actually representing them many of the
time sometimes he is
and i will disagree with that too but a
lot of times what the leadership is
doing
isn't reflective of what the people want
and that's exactly how we got ourselves
into the situation in the first place
that's why we put that tea in the harbor
because those leaders were not
responsible to or representing what the
people wanted yeah
i saw the other day this uh clip
online and it was this it was charles
barkley
and he said in his heart he really
believes most people are good
uh he thinks that it's there are people
in this country who can divide us
by and he said to be fair on the right
and the left there are people that can
divide us by just getting us whipped up
on hating the other side it helps
polarize us
and we can't get anything done and he
actually felt like there was more we
could accomplish
that we're not as far apart as we think
we are and i thought that was a very
hopeful message
you know and it's true um there's an
organization called beyond conflict
and they have worked in literally
war-torn societies all over the world
for decades
and the aftermath of civil wars that's
real division when folks are taking up
guns and machetes and lobbing ieds at
each other
right okay so they have done studies
there and practices to bring folks
together and what they found here in the
us
is that we're not as divided as we think
we are and the way they did it they
asked
for example democrats what do you think
republicans think of you
as a democrat and on a scale of one
they hate me 10 they want to marry me
and have all my babies
they're like democrats oh they feel a
one toward me they want to destroy me
right and then they said republicans
what do you think of democrats and i was
like i don't know four
yeah yeah right it's like there's a gap
there's a distortion
there's a perception distortion and
that's where leadership matters yeah
that's why i was so excited about joe
biden who i was i was not writing for
joe biden
i was more of a bernie type of person
right and
but i respected joe biden's awareness of
his power to lead
by language by example by channeling
what's in all of us there's good in all
of us yeah there is bad
in all of us and someone can pull
one level or the other and whip us into
that frenzy that you talked about
or they can say hey that person is kind
of similar to you
yeah i think we might be in this more
together than a part
why do we play that part up right and uh
so yeah we're it's not as bad in some
cases as it seems
it is still real and it is and that's
the kind of the complexity it's like i'm
not trying to say
we're already united everything's great
it's not great
yeah it just isn't and to be fit and and
to be fair i've there's stuff
i make it a practice to i will tune in
to fox to see what they're saying
oh bless you um well i just i want to
support them in any way i can you have a
timer or
what's the how do you manage this it's a
feeling you get inside
uh it helps me digest i do tiny doses
you know what i do dose lsd i like dose
boxes yeah
micro micro dose of fox news is terrific
it uh it raises the uh
the blood pressure in a way that's quite
healthy yeah um no i like to see
i like to flip around and see how
different people are covering the same
story
and i'll get irritated when i see
sometimes cnn doing the same thing or
msnbc doing
a version of what they're doing on fox
news just the opposite tact
and harping on the negative and i think
i do think sometimes that yes there's
money in the extremes there's money to
be made in the extremes and the money is
in
extreme opinions on the left and on the
right
and that's what whips people into this
negative state
sometimes which bums me out and i think
it's also a lack of imagination on the
part of people trying to make that money
right
you look at social media which has
turned us all up to 11
and how it amplifies disagreements and
there's profit
in that and it's laziness right there's
there's a different algorithm
which doesn't have us grabbing
pitchforks trying to stab the other
person in the eye
yeah they just stumbled on the cheap one
first i think
yeah i certainly hope it's the first
thought yeah not this like the best
thought is the easy money thought yeah
yeah and it's like let's evolve
let's do better than that maybe let's
have more people involved who are
impacted by these systems in the first
place
again democracy there i go you know the
people having power and a say over the
systems that influence them
that's the ticket through most of this
stuff right
it was funny i was driving to work
yesterday
and this truck drove by me and it was
like the guy was honking his horn
i mean just in general at anybody and he
had a giant flag
and the flag said socialism sucks
and and uh exclamation point okay and
this flag coming out
in out of his car and i thought who's
forcing socialists upon you like
i think socialism for this guy is a
buzzword for
anyone who doesn't agree completely with
his narrow agenda
is socialism i kind of wanted to run him
off the road and say
explain socialism to me and he probably
wouldn't be able to
socialism is the uh the public hospital
he gets taken to
after you run him off the road right
exactly and we have to deny that service
if you hate socialism wait a minute is
this for free
yes forget it send that stimulus check
back too
and also while you're at it get off this
public roads yes exactly
socialist demonstration of engineering
i don't want anybody fixing these roads
that's [ __ ] yeah uh you say that
there
are uh very simple like
ways to citizen like three or four ways
to citizen can you give them to me in a
nutshell so i can then
maybe do one of them but not all three
or four they're conceptual i
speak in we a lot when i talk about this
show i say we thought about this and we
my wife is my like partner in
architecting
how we approach the subject oh wait so
you and your wife agree on things
let's talk about that
can i talk to you for seven hours you
can absolutely do that we'll make time
um so yeah we wanted to make sure that
we weren't just making stuff up
in candy b's just turn on the microphone
and just tell people things
and so it's like what do we believe that
this word should mean if we interpret
citizen as a verb
four things it means we show up and
participate there's an active thing yep
so just show up
do something get in the game yeah second
it means we recognize
that we are dependent on others that we
need each other
so we invest in relationships with other
people you can't citizen alone
i remember when the u.s had this motto
for the army
army of one that didn't make a lot of
sense to me because that's not an
army that's a dude with a gun and also
no one's afraid of an army of one no
that's just oh that's jerry you know all
right you've asked for it we're sending
jerry
yeah no one's intimidated by jerry so we
need other people so let's work on that
and invest in other people in our
relationships
the third is really important is
understanding our power and i think so
much
so many times um our power as citizens
gets reduced to voting
it's like you have amazing power as
citizens in a democracy and your
your power is to give that power to
someone else right
every two or four years and hope they do
a good job maybe harass them by faxing
them every now and then with your
demands
we can spend our money in certain ways
we associate with people or not
we share certain ideas or not we gather
physically
in protest or celebration that's all
forms of power so we need to understand
that power that's the third
and the last is we do all this for the
benefit of the many
not just the few and our first guest in
the first season
a brilliant woman named valerie core
wrote this book called see no stranger
and the idea was a stranger is a part of
me i do not yet know
so let me treat everybody as a part of
myself
let me love myself let me love others
let me even love my opponents
and through that act of love not the
sentimental kind but a deeper
civic kind of love right we can move
this whole thing forward so
if everybody is connected if we're all
in this together
then when we do things for the many
socialist leaning things like public
roads or hospitals or education
or healthcare then we're doing it for
ourselves too
i love that that a stranger is the part
of me i don't know
i absolutely love that valerie core said
it yeah yeah yeah
it can be misused if you're getting too
close to someone on a bus
that's what i'm going to use from now on
when we're like hey back off pal
you're the part of me i don't know
um that is fantastic uh thank you so
much for stopping in
seriously this has been fantastic
beautiful it's chill
yeah this is about his i'm highly
medicated um
thank you for being here and classing up
the joint a little bit uh season two
of how to citizen with baratunde is now
available on
all podcast platforms and it's a rare
thing it's a podcast doing some good
something i'm clearly not in favor of
and if folks want to learn more yeah you
can go to the website we have
howtocitizen.com
we're rolling out more features there's
a podcast but we're also
i think we really believe in helping
people through this because i know
from personal experience i wanted to do
more
yeah there's so many people i mean
scientists were marching conan like
people want to do stuff they're so
people are popping up refrigerators to
feed people in their communities
what else can we do so we're asking and
trying to answer that question
with the with the people all right well
thank you so much
baratunde thurston and uh let's do this
again
conan o'brien you got yourself a deal
and i'm sorry for running you off the
road that time
it was you in the car i didn't realize
you were so passionate
socialism sucks